Adam is in Ohio hey Adam welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hey Dave how are you
doing better than I deserve what's up so
I'll try to be quick for you of course
my wife and I have four children she is
a stay-at-home mom I make about 32 to 35
thousand a year together we have about a
hundred thousand in debt we are kind of
new to the grantee thing so we're trying
to got the money the app and all that
we're going through most of the debt is
mine I have about eighty thousand of the
debt with thirty thousand of it being
student loans thirty of your Navy is
student rooms yes okay what is the other
fifty um
I co-signed for a car when I was 18 and
that's 20 thousand and the car got
repoed and I have some stuff for school
that wasn't covered by student loans
some medical things and just kind of
like all small things add up
I have no credit cards whatsoever some
other small things add up to $30,000
well with the the cars 20,000 of it yeah
I owe another Iowa College 14,000 and
then I owe some like two different
medical bills that come up to ten
thousand and then another five thousand
is to another school so okay and what's
your degree in um I did not get to
finish due to having kids so I want to
go back but now I want to be able to
like pay for it instead of taking out
more student loans okay what were you
studying
um eyes biology I am about a year away
like if I went back now I may have to do
longer just because of the time frame
but I had about a year left to get my
biology degree I got you how old are you
I'm 27 okay and what's the other 20,000
that your wife had um she has about oh
she has 20,000 as student loans also
then get to finish her degree and 2,000
is medical okay
all right okay and your questions what
um we know that it's a big no-no in you
so I I kind of feel like I know the
answer but I was debating if I should
file bankruptcy due to the massive
amount of my loan and then the fact I
only make thirty to thirty five thousand
because one of the debts that I owe are
attempting garnishment and it'll take
25% of my take-home pay which would be a
lot for my family who's attempting
garnishment I'm one of the universities
that I owe about fourteen thousand okay
yeah all right I'll tell you what well
it's not a big no-no in the sense of
like I'm mad at you or something it's
just a matter of what does it do any
good number one and then number two I
always put bankruptcy and divorce in the
same bucket you try everything you can
try to keep from doing it anything you
can do to avoid it we avoid it and then
sometimes good people face that I went
through a bank run you know and I I'm
not proud of that and I wouldn't
recommend it I've got a friend went
through a divorce he's not proud of that
but he wouldn't recommend it but he
survived it and there's life the other
side of it but it's a it's a life
altering occurrence you know and so we
want to look at it and analyze it and
say what is anything we can do to avoid
it you got a pretty pretty big mess here
for sure no question about that can you
hold with me through the break and let's
break it down a little bit on the other
side of the commercials absolutely thank
you I'll be right back with you
talking with Adam in Ohio $32,000 income
for kids
120 mm mortars in death
30 and student loans on him 20 on his
wife that's 50 of the 120 20 in a repo
14 at a college that's coming after them
with a garnishment tenants from medical
5 and another school alone and so on -
and another medical a lot of stuff
piling up and not much income and it's
been a while and he's been getting beat
up wondering wondering if he needs to
file bankruptcy is that a fair summary
of what you told me so far sir yeah it
is it's a hundred K total though not 120
X I'm not happy with the hundred I don't
want to add oh I must have added it
wrong okay all right well the oh yeah
you said eighty was yours that's right I
didn't yeah okay
either way it's it's overwhelming alive
or what yeah and the garnishment coming
etch is what's prompting this so here's
the thing
if you file bankruptcy you're still
going to have the $50,000 in student
loan debt yeah it survives the
bankruptcy so we're filing bankruptcy on
about $60,000 and it gets rid of the
garnishment and you probably there's
what's called a means test when you go
into file bankruptcy and if you make too
much money your income indicates you can
pay your debts then they put you into a
chapter 13 which is a payment plan not a
chapter 7 I think you'll pass that means
test looking at this and you probably
will qualify for a chapter 7 which would
wipe everything else off except those
two student loans so that's what
bankruptcy would do for you and
obviously that would be a relief the
thing I always want to look at and I
want to make sure you're looking at and
help you with is two things when I filed
bankruptcy the attorney was a character
but he did say a couple of things that
were wise one of them he said make sure
you protect your marriage because
financial stress will destroy your
marriage and that no kiddin we were
about to kill each other at that moment
he I guess he saw the black eye sure and
it given me I don't know but
the second thing he said was bankruptcy
does not create an income and what
you've had is a long career a long
period of time where you've been stuck
on your career your career sucks and
it's not getting better when I'm trying
to say yeah and bankruptcy is not going
to solve that you're still going to be
sitting there with $50,000 in debt for
kids at $32,000 a year you're still
slightly above the poverty level at that
point right so it's not it's still gonna
be a mess
so bankruptcies not really it's gonna
help but it's not gonna solve everything
so versus like as an example the stupid
college may force you into it because
you may have to do it to protect your
income to feed your kids you can't lose
25 percent of $32,000 to a garnishment
no I'm like no no you can't you can't
feed your family keep your lights on
than that so they may force you into it
if they do that
you mean you may mathematically not be
left with any options I hope that is not
the case yeah but what's your overall
problem when we solve your overall
problems when we solve your career
problem you have an income problem
agreed yeah the sad thing is is for my
area I'm actually feeling pretty close
no you're not the only other jobs no
you're not it sucks
you're not doing good at all I mean
you're starving to death man
it's not that you're a bad person or you
don't work hard that's not what I'm
saying
you're not making money I mean if you
live in an area where 32,000 is a high
income it's time to move yeah yeah where
do you live Toledo Ohio the only other
place that's going to get me more money
than that right now is factories are
going and finishing out my degree or
starting a business Toledo Ohio has a
lot of successful business people Toledo
Ohio has contractors that make money
Toledo Ohio has AI
people that make money Toledo Ohio is
people who design websites Toledo Ohio
is not a depressed market where the
average income is $32,000 that's just
not true man you're stuck right now and
you're you've had the crap beat out of
you so I'm being your coach at halftime
when you're behind and I'm saying you
got more in you than you realize and I'm
trying to say let's go play the second
half better I think we've got a no we've
got to work on your income regardless of
if you file bankruptcy or not you've got
to double your income in the next three
or four years and it's not necessarily
going back to school it's just a better
choice of where you're working and what
you're doing because but you've been
doing this for like five years right
yeah yeah it's not getting any better
so that that's what I would tell you I
hope you can avoid the bankruptcy
because here's the thing let's just
pretend for a second let's just dream
for a second then you can start making
60,000 and you could pick up a side
hustle and your wife picked up a side
hustle and made another ten that adds 20
to this now we're at 80 people do this
counting all the time you heard them
doing the debt free screams okay I don't
know if you're cutting glass or blowing
leaves I don't know if you're making
websites I don't know if you're cutting
hair I don't know what we're doing let's
just pretend though let's just pretend
that was possible because it is if you
did all of that I sudden you guys are so
used to living on nothing for five years
you've been living on nothing if I had
$50,000 a year coming in extra above
what you got coming in now I can solve
this entire thing in under two years and
you're not bankrupt you see right so I
mean you could pay a hundred percent
these bills and you could by the way you
could settle these old medical bills you
can settle the other old school that you
probably sell this 14,000 for 50 cents
on the dollar or 25 cents on the dollar
if you had a little cash to throw at
them if you offered them three or four
thousand bucks today they'd probably
take it but you don't have three or four
thousand bucks getting that yeah yeah
that's the problem
so and you probably don't have anything
you could sell because you guys have
been living hand-to-mouth and again I'm
not shaming you
I'm not saying you're a bad guy at all
you don't hear that okay all I'm saying
is you got more potential than you've
been getting out of this and the math is
not going to get easier until we get the
income side of this equation up so
that's where we want to help you if we
can and if you can get some more income
coming in you can say you can probably
settle that repo for easily 20 cents on
the dollar so four grand will settle
that you can settle those medicals for
probably 20 cents on the dollar they're
five years old probably settle these
couple school lunch and I gonna sell the
student loans themselves out like that
but all sudden this 100,000 starts
turning into about 50 or 60 or 80
thousand bucks on settlements with lump
sums and now you got some cash to throw
at it because we've changed your income
but changing your income is the part of
the math equation we have to have to do
to make that a possibility so that's
what I'm hopeful for for you and Ken
Coleman is our career guy here at Ramsey
I'm going to send you a copy of his book
the proximity principle and I want you
and your wife to put the kids to bed it
to bed early tonight turn off everything
in the house get a little cup of hot
chocolate and sit and dream again like
you used to when you're 17 or 18 of what
you want to be when you grow up that
pays seventy thousand dollars a year or
a hundred and seventy thousand dollars a
year and what are the steps to get there
and don't tell me you got to go back and
get a hundred thousand dollar loan to
get a student loan to go to school to
get there you don't so what are what are
the steps to go be what you want to be
three years from now two years from now
making much much more money for you and
your family that's what's going to be
necessary here for you because if you
live this way for the next 20 years
you're gonna struggle you're going to
struggle and I don't want that for you
man so hold on Kelly's gonna pick up
we're gonna give you a copy of ken
Coleman's book the proximity principle
Kelly also throw in a book called start
for him out of our library and one of
them that we published awhile back start
because this he needs to start fresh
this is a fresh start thing we reboot
this thing reboot this computer cold
restart
well my computer's not working I don't
know how to fix it because I'm horrible
with computers but I know cold restart
turning completely off turn it back on
solves a whole lot of problems takes a
few minutes
this always solves a lot of the problems
and that's true of a lot of things in
life a man you called me back if I can
help more I hope you're not forced into
this bankruptcy let's see if we can
fight our way through it but dreaming
again